[Music]
tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates how
could Jeffrey Epstein the federal prison
systems highest profile inmate end up
dead we are now learning of serious
irregularities at this facility but the
investigation of Epstein sex trafficking
operation remains ongoing with new
questions about his powerful friend
then again epsy knew a lot of powerful
and important people including Alan
Dershowitz former New Mexico Governor
Bill Richardson Prince Andrew as well as
President Bill Clinton and President
Donald Trump it is a who's who of who's
Jeffrey Epstein I've never met Jeffrey
empty before Epstein there was FBI
informant Whitey Bulger murdered in a
federal prison in West Virginia the real
conspiracy maybe one of incompetence
corruption and brutality
plus our shoutout for the journalists
whose investigations sent hundreds of
thousands of people to the streets and
led to the resignation of a governor the
power of the people from the law and
crime Network studios in New York City's
Herald Square this is Brian Ross
investigates good evening and welcome
tonight how could one of the country's
most high-profile prisoners end up dead
in a federal prison cell it's a question
that can be asked about Jeffrey Epstein
the accused sex trafficker with friends
in high places but it could also be
asked about Whitey Bulger the infamous
FBI organized crime informant who was
murdered in a federal prison in West
Virginia in October of last year so
tonight we focus on the Federal Bureau
of Prisons which runs both of those
facilities with these two mysterious
deaths putting a harsh spotlight on the
Bo P as it's called
heads have already rolled at the
Metropolitan Corrections Center in New
York where Jeffrey Epstein was being
held
the warden transferred two guards put on
leave and the Attorney General promising
a full investigation we are now learning
of serious irregularities at this
facility that are deeply concerning and
demand a thorough investigation within
hours of Epstein's death there were wild
conspiracy theories about what happened
no doubt triggered by the powerful
people who had once been Epstein's
friends then again MC knew a lot of
powerful and important people including
Alan Dershowitz former New Mexico
Governor Bill Richardson Prince Andrew
as well as President Bill Clinton and
President Donald Trump it is a who's who
of who's Jeffrey Epstein I've never met
Jeffrey ante Internet theories claimed
Epstein had been murdered to protect his
powerful friends a claim that President
Trump included in one of his tweets that
reached millions of people
[Music]
reports in the New York Times and
elsewhere revealed what was more likely
a conspiracy of incompetence overworked
or sleeping guards strict protocols
regularly ignored ABC News has learned
guards were supposed to check on the
alleged sex trafficker every 30 minutes
sources say that protocol was not
followed in the hours before he was
discovered but before Epstein there was
Whitey Bulger a former FBI informant
murdered at a federal prison in West
Virginia within hours of being
transferred there a place where at least
five of the inmates were behind bars
because of Bulger ratting them out to
the FBI
Boulder's eyes were nearly gouged out
and two inmates including a convicted
mafia hitman were seen on surveillance
video entering Bulger cell Tuesday
morning the FBI also promised a full
investigation in the wake of bulges
murder but so far no one has been
charged and there has been no public
explanation of how such a high-profile
inmate could end up in the general
population of a prison where a number of
men had strong motives to kill him the
Bureau of Prisons and his acting
director Hugh Hurwitz did not respond to
our request for an official to appear on
our program tonight which is par for the
course with that agency which over the
years has repeatedly acted in a manner
suggesting both incompetence and
arrogance there's not been a permanent
director there since General Mark inche
abruptly resigned last year citing
matters of conscience but we're joined
now by people who do know a lot about
what happens in those federal prisons
starting here in the studio with Susan
Kellerman a New York lawyer who
represents a number of clients who've
been held in the same facility as
Jeffrey Epstein also here is a Vela star
an investigative reporter who's been
focusing on the MCC here in New York
long before Epstein was found dead in
his cell also joining us by Skype is
Tyrone Covington the national vice
president of the labor union which
represents federal prison guards and
Cameron Lindsey a former senior official
at the Federal Bureau of Prisons who has
served as a warden in a number of its
facilities including here in New York
mr. Cameron let me start with you and
let's deal first with the question of
what happened to Jeffrey Epstein was it
suicide was it murder and whatever it
was
how could that happen with a prisoner
who had already been put on a suicide
watch
at least once very frankly I don't know
how it happened it should have never
happened it's shocking and disturbing I
believe that was a suicide the only
possible way that it could have been a
homicide is if the staff put another
inmate inside the jail cell I've heard
the media outlets talk about how there
should have been another inmate in the
cell with him to serve as like a
companion to ensure that he did not kill
himself Epstein that is very frankly
from my perspective that would be a
severe security breach in and of itself
I believe that Epstein should have been
single celled from the very moment that
he walked into the door and he should
have stayed that way and until he would
have gone out the door and the reason
for that is in the subculture of jails
and prisons it's a badge of honor
to be able to take out the likes of
Jeffrey Epstein here's a guy that was
already convicted pedophile he's accused
of human trafficking assault on young
girls with wide publicity so he would
have made an excellent target in any
prison or jail so he should have never
been celled with anybody at any time if
that did happen I see that is as a as an
error procedural operational error
tyrone covington let me ask you two of
the guards have been placed on leave
they apparently were sleeping they may
have falsified the logs and lied about
it
what's your insight on this I will tell
you I believe that we must get back to
staff the benefit of the doubt here
until the FBI G completes their
investigation we're not talking about
folks if this did happen in a man is
being described we went to work with the
pillow in a blanket and say I'm going to
sleep
these were staff who were overworked
overwhelmed in a system that is so
understaffed in this was only a matter
of time that something like this would
happen and we have to get the staffing
levels up within the federal prisons of
course the system
Aviva Stoll you've been reporting on
what's been going on of the MCC for some
time now you're not surprised by what
happened
not surprised I think for a long time
MCC has had an issue with understaffing
and overcrowded and like other people I
mentioned but also missile health has
been a really sir underserved medical
need I believe that in both MCC and MDC
the sister facility in Brooklyn there's
one psychiatrist to serve the five
hundred people who are diagnosed with
severe mental illness and then only a
handful of therapist to handle everyone
who needs any kind of milk mental health
treatment from what I understand people
even receive mental health treatment
through this law and their door and I
it's no wonder that if Jeffrey Epstein
was suicidal that he wasn't getting the
treatment he needed
Susan Kalman as a lawyer you've been in
and out of that facility quite a bit are
the conditions there as bad as it's been
described and if this can happen with a
high profile in mud like Jeffrey Epstein
how about all the others are there how
about all the others because the MCC
they describe it as horrific is really
not to say enough and you know you would
just leave always just talking about
therapy through the slots I have young
clients 19 20 year olds who is so in
need of mental health treatment and the
court has ordered it on from time to
time and they describe to me exactly
that that the therapist comes by how're
you feeling today booming before they
answer the slot is closed and they move
on to somebody else these are kids that
were reaching out they need help I mean
some of them that described to me their
mother's a 14 years old and then they
have five children by the time they're
19 years old those mothers are lost but
their kids are too and these kids are
reaching out this one young man asked me
for books so that he could learn about
how to this is his words how to find his
purpose in life and every book I sent
him was returned they wouldn't let him
get them for no reason I mean I I've
gotten to the point where I literally
send the books to their chief counsel
who is gracious enough to at least
entertain getting the books to my
clients we have a question for you from
our control room from executive producer
Schwartz Rhonda Susan let me ask you
prisoners are always complaining that's
what the public thinks what do you say
it of folks who say you know they're
that this is a complaint of prisoners
well they are always complaining but
they're always complaining because
they're treated like dirt under
somebody's shoe and the reality is I
think part of it in fairness to the
institution if we want to be fair in the
institution is it's terribly overcrowded
and horrific ly understaffed and when
you're an officer who's doing the job of
three people or five people and
back-to-back shifts it's not a surprise
that you're falling asleep it's not a
surprise that you can't do your job
nobody could do their job under those
circumstances and then god forbid
somebody wants to be fed on top of it
and that's really an incursion into
their private space so we know under the
Trump administration there was a hiring
freeze which was lifted put back on
lifted again mr. Lindsay what's the
impact of that kind of action it's
significant Brian and this has been
going on forever I'm not going to
tribute it to one administration or
another this has been going on forever
my humble perspective is we have got to
do something in this country in terms of
criminal justice reform and I'm talking
about all components of the so-called
criminal justice system there really is
no criminal justice system but a
multitude of systems comprised of local
state and federal police courts and
corrections and frankly we need to learn
how to incarcerate better we've got to
do a better job at that prison
administrators from my perspective I
believe have a an ethical moral and
constitutional responsibility to ensure
that inmates are incarcerated as
punishment and not for punishment so
we've got an awful lot of work to do and
the people who are in the MCC in large
part are people who are innocent
awaiting trial and yet we've reported on
them they're treated in the most brutal
manner yeah I think it's important also
if for people who are thinking well
prisoners complain all the time to think
actually what life and MCC is like so
one thing that I've heard about from
prisoners
or from detainees since they're not
technically convicted is that the
plumbing bricks all the time so I read
one lawsuit where a prisoner described
how the toilet stops working and they
were forced to defecate into bag the
sort defecate in the shower and then a
woman contacted me just a couple of
months ago and told me a woman holds at
MCC and she told me that the toilet had
overflowed and they were trapped they
were cleaning feces up with their hands
and with their clothes and that's how
they were expected to live in this
facility and Tyrone Covington from the
point of view of the Union represent the
guards you must hear the same sort of
complaints about them over work they
fall asleep they're in a situation they
can't win and they're understaffed
absolutely we hear this all the time and
we've have you know fortunately trajan
bar did come in and lift the hiring
freeze that was placed on and now must
have Lindsey the staffing issues have
been going on long but we put a hiring
freeze in on top of that it really was
problematic so fortunately that was able
to be done those staff who work at MCC I
must say are tremendous people they have
been placed in a situation unlike this
they choose not to work 18 in 20 hours
in some cases 24 I was believe it or not
within this institution they were giving
us its circumstances mr. Lindsey let me
ask you this is a suicide preventable at
a federal prison does it have to happen
because there are lots of them it seems
if not all but this one was especially
preventable and I'm just not going to
blame this incident on correctional
officers now why I certainly don't
condone inattention to duty if there
were officers that were sleeping I would
never condone that but very frankly that
this this is an issue the suicide of
Jeffrey Epstein is this is an issue and
in my opinion of sound correctional
leadership and decision-making or lack
thereof I'm not trying to bad-mouth the
warden there I don't know who he or she
is it's a hard job
I was awarding to five facilities three
prisons and two jails
it's an arduous very difficult
profession but
honestly everything that happens inside
a federal prison or jail is on the
responsibility of the warden and you
have you have got to be involved in
critical decision-making such as this
Jeffrey Epstein should have been left on
suicide watch subsequent to his first
account that's really the bottom line
here but there's also the issue I think
in the broader scope here of complaints
by prisoners about abuse at the hands of
guards which almost never are confirmed
or found in favor of the inmates they
always take the guards word for it maybe
that's correct what do you think Susan
Koman well you know there's a process at
the MCC and at the MDC where if an
inmate has a complaint they can file a
complaint and before we can ever bring
it to the court's attention the inmate
we have to be able to establish that the
inmate filed a complaint and pursued it
and there was an action taken and then
they can file an appeal and all this is
administrative and bureaucratic but I
have one client a young man who's there
right now who he's in a special unit the
door can't be opened unless there's a
lieutenant present but they don't have a
lieutenant assigned to his unit so
sometimes he gets his breakfast at 8:00
in the morning and sometimes he gets it
at 2:00 in the afternoon and that's his
breakfast sometimes he gets lunch and
sometimes he doesn't but that's because
they have nobody assigned to that unit
who's allowed to open the door they are
treated so badly and that largely I
think because they just don't have the
staff I don't know if they do it
differently if they had the staff but
they don't have the staff and so it
there's just no possibility for people
to be treated humanely this also this
kid complains all the time
that he never gets to sleep at night and
one of the many abuses is by leaving the
lights on 24/7 what is the point of that
they have a switch right outside the
cell so if they want to look inside they
can look inside and by the way I've
heard many a commentator in the last
week talked about how there's no cameras
in those cells because that would be an
invasion of privacy inmates don't have
privacy that's the most nonsensical
thing I've heard some of those cells
have one video camera in them some of
them have two and the inmates will cover
them just so they can go to the bathroom
in private but they are monitors
everywhere now they could all be broken
because everything is
broke in there but it seems to me in a
place where there's cameras everywhere
there's an answer to what happened to
Jeffrey Epstein we're just not being
told what it is well Susan thank you
very much I want to thank all of our
guests today for some fascinating
insights tonight
Cameron lindsay tyrone covington and
here in the studio Susan Coleman and
Aviva Stoll collectively what you've
told us really is nothing less than a
disgraceful scandal in the way our
federal prisons are being run who's
guarding the guards up next our shout
out for the investigative reporters
whose stories triggered massive protests
and ultimately
the resignation of a governor when we
return
and our shutout tonight for a small band
of investigative reporters who have had
an outsized impact on the officials
they've been covering for years in the
u.s. territory of Puerto Rico when more
than a hundred thousand people took to
the streets in San Juan Puerto Rico this
summer demanding the ouster of the
governor and other local officials it
was the direct result of the work of a
small team of investigative reporters at
Puerto Rico's center for investigative
journalism led by executive director
Carla Burnett we were definitely we
never expected something like this would
have would happen we just thought that
there were so many things wrong with the
governor and his closest advisors and
officials that we thought that everybody
had to know how they were talking who
they were talking about and what was the
tone that they were using and it all
came in an almost 900 page transcript of
an online messaging a chat it's called
between the governor and his closest
associates and advisors documents turned
over by a confidential source the
governor called one rival a whore he
wrote about another we must liquidate
him today one of the governor's deputies
brought about a frequent critic of the
governor I am salivating to shoot her
you you would never expect something
like that from a government official
about their own political party a lies
about the poor people about women about
LGBT community about everyone you know
you wouldn't expect that just to see it
in black and white it was awful it must
have been amazing to see it right there
in front of you it was it was we were
speechless their story came as the
people of Puerto Rico were still trying
to recover from two devastating
hurricanes and the snide comments from
the governor and his cronies Minette
says proved to be a kind of tipping
point in the public outrage
they just in general they they talk in a
very disrespectful way about the victims
and I think that hurt many people you
know everybody here in Puerto Rico went
through a lot because of the hurricane a
former top aide of the governor wrote
about the growing problem with dead
bodies quote now that we are on the
subject don't we have some cadavers to
feed our crows within days of the
group's publication of the governor's
chats the crowds began to form on the
streets of San Juan leading to some
violent confrontations by police around
11:00 p.m. and that sent protesters
running first Governor Ricardo was
shallow said he had no intention of
stepping down there are a hundred
thousand people on the streets
politicians of all stripes the President
of the United States all saying you need
to go that this is enough you've said no
why not well there's there's an
important component of a rule of law and
democracy and I respect that process but
the protest continued fueled by the
ongoing reporting of the Center for
Investigative Journalism and then siento
que continúa against opposition after
hours of delay rocío finally said the
words these people had been waiting 12
days to hear I will be resigning
[Applause]
I have to say I was not surprised
everybody expected that to happen we
were expecting that to happen because he
had no other choice but when it happened
did you feel like oh my goodness we
caused this well you know I don't see it
as we caused this I see it like as the
people the their part you know we do so
many stories that never have this kind
of outcome so I think it was it was the
people's doing what happened in the end
the Center for Investigative Journalism
and his reporters were applauded across
the island and by prominent journalists
in New York and Washington the prize is
appreciated Manette says but it creates
expectations for a lot more you know we
are very concerned about trying to catch
up with what people expect from us you
know we are also citizens we have
families we live here and of course we
are concerned about the outcomes of this
process but we feel that socially it has
been a great lesson for everyone in
Puerto Rico and also for other countries
and for other states and territories a
lesson about the power of the press yeah
definitely the power of the press and
the power of the people and the power of
the people I like how she told me we're
both citizens and journalists so our
shout out tonight to Puerto Rico center
for investigative journalism keep up the
good work down there that's our program
for tonight
thanks so much for joining us we'll see
you back here on the law and crime
Network next week good night